>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Levon Avdoyan: It's inconceivable
to me that we gather here today,
diplomats, congressional staffers,
colleagues, friends, family,
not only for the 20th annual
Vardanants Day Armenia lecture,
but also for the 25th anniversary
of the Republic of Armenia.
And of the Dadian Grant,
which reinvigorated the
Armenian collections and programs
at the Library of Congress.
None of this has been
achieved by a single person.
We are a library.
We collaborate.
The special evens office,
the communications office,
and my colleagues both
here and in cataloging
and acquisitions divisions,
have been here from the start.
I would like to begin, however,
with a person for the last decade
who has been a great supporter
of the Armenian programs
and initiatives.
She believes not only
collecting and servicing all
of our country's resources, but also
in presenting them to the public
with events such as
this lecture series.
Please join me in welcoming Dr. Mary
Jane-Deeb, the chief of the African
and Middle Eastern Division.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb:
Okay, well thank you
and thank you all for being here.
On behalf of everyone in the
African Middle East Division,
I would like to welcome you to
this library and to this wonderful,
beautiful hole that we call
the Northeast Pavilion.
I'm delighted to see you all
here on this special occasion
when we celebrate, as Dr.
Avdoyan has just mentioned,
the 20th annual Vardanants Day
lecture, one of the longest series
of lectures of its
kind a the library.
With a presentation by Professor
Christina Maranci, the Arthur Dadian
and Ara Oztemel professor
of Armenian art
and architecture history
at Tufts University.
It is only because of the hard work
and dedication of Dr. Levon Avdoyan,
the Armenian-Georgia
specialist in this division,
and the generous financial
support of the Arthur
and Marjorie Dadian fund that this
unique lecture series at the Library
of Congress was made possible
and thrive for two decades.
I would also like to join
Dr. Avdoyan in thanking you
for your presence here today, and
especially to you who have traveled
from many parts of the
United States to be with us.
And thank you Ambassador
Hovhannissian
for having taking the time
off your busy schedule
to join us for today's event.
Before we start, let me tell you
something about our division.
I always do this.
This is our special commercial.
But, so although Armenian
films, photographs music,
maps and other items can be found
throughout this vast library,
we hold most of the materials
in the Armenian language.
We keep and preserve rare
manuscripts written and illustrated
by Armenian scholars and artists.
We serve our readers books,
newspapers and periodicals
that are published in Armenia,
as well as in the diaspora.
And Dr. Avdoyan briefs
scholars, politicians,
as he did when the president
of Armenia was here a year ago,
as well as school children and
visitors from other parts of America
and other parts of the world
about the Armenian collections.
And now lest you think that we are
the Armenian division of the Library
of Congress, we do this as
well for other countries
for which we are responsible
in the Middle East in Africa,
in Central Asia and the Caucuses.
And now here to welcome you
to the library is a
deputy librarian David Mao.
David served as acting librarian
of Congress until last week
when a new librarian of Congress
Dr. Carla Hayden was sworn
and took office, was sworn in.
He's a graduate of the
George Washington University
and the Georgetown University
Law Center and is admitted
to the District of Columbia Bar.
He received a graduate
degree in library science
from the Catholic University of
America and has practiced law
for several years, including at the
prestigious international law firm
of Covington and Burling and has
had various positions at the Library
of Congress, including being the law
librarian and the acting librarian
of Congress in the position in
which he has acted incredibly,
superlatively well.
Reorganizing many parts of the
library within a very short time.
So let me now call upon
him to address you.
So David Mao.
[ Applause ]
>> David Mao: Good
afternoon everyone.
Thank you very much Mary-Jane
for that very kind introduction.
And Mr. Ambassador
we're greatly honored
that you're able to
join us here today.
As you heard, my name is David Mao,
and I am the deputy
librarian of congress.
We do have a new 14th
librarian of congress here,
only the 14th in our 216 years of
history at the Library of Congress.
We're very excited.
We had a wonderful swearing
in ceremony last week.
Dr. Hayden could not join us
here today, but I do extend
on her behalf a great welcome
to all of you, Mr. Ambassador,
to all of our friends for being
here in this wonderful pavilion
and really to this wonderful
event, the 20th anniversary,
the 20th Vardanants Day
lecture here at the library.
As you have heard from Lee,
Armenian collections and programs,
that's not new here at the library.
We've been doing it
for quite some time
through the generous support
of many, many friends.
And the Vardanants Day lecture,
this is the 20th lecture
here at the library.
And since 1994 when the first
lecture was held, scholars,
members of congress, members of
the diplomatic core, musicians
and even scientists have spoken all
about Armenia, to celebrate Armenia.
And we're just extremely delighted
that we can continue
this tradition here.
As you can see, we are
filming this lecture.
All of our previous lectures are
available on the library's website,
and they're quite popular.
I'm told that the 17th Vardanants
Day lecture on DNA and the origins
of the Armenian people has
generated over 62,000 viewings
on our website, which is fantastic.
I suspect that our
lecture today is going
to generate many more than that.
I myself had the privilege of
visiting Armenia in April of 2012,
and as I think back,
visiting the [inaudible],
seeing the Geghard Monestary and
getting to meet the Catholicos
when I was at Etchmiadzin.
It was just incredible experiences
which is why I'm extremely honored
to be able to welcome all of you to
this program on such a special day
on this the 25th anniversary
of the Republic
of Armenia's Declaration
of Independence.
If you have not been to Armenia,
I really recommend that you go.
It was just an incredible
experience,
and I hopefully have the opportunity
to go once more sometime
in the future.
So again, welcome to the
library and enjoy the program.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: Thank
you Mr. Mao, David.
I wanted to mention also that
David represented the Library
of Congress in Yerevan in 2012.
And ever since, I at least have
considered him an honorary Armenian.
And Mr. Ambassador, I think
you could probably confer
that honor on him.
Good. Twenty-five years
ago on this very day,
Armenia proclaimed its
independence from the Soviet Union.
Since that time, a series
of diplomats, both American
and Armenian, has sought
to create relationships
that did not previously exist.
Armenia has been well-served
by the ambassadors it
has sent to this post.
And particularly well-served by
his Excellency Grigor Hovhannissian
who reported in January
of this year.
Ambassador Hovhannissian
has served in a variety
of posts throughout the world,
both for the Republic of Armenia
and for the United Nations with
an extensive educational resume
that includes the Haigazian
University of Beirut
and the Fletcher School at Tufts.
I hope Ambassador Hovhannissian
will accept,
both as the Armenian specialist
and as a second generation
American-Armenian,
my sincere congratulations
to the Republic
on achieving this milestone.
And I am delighted that
Ambassador Hovhannissian has agreed
to say a few words on his
wonderful anniversary.
Mr. Ambassador.
[ Applause ]
>> Grigor Hovhannissian: Thank you
Mr. Avdoyan, Mr. Mao, Miss Deeb,
dear friends, colleagues.
I can't think of a better way
of celebrating Armenia's
independence than in this center.
One of the most important
centers in the world of knowledge,
of preserving the knowledge,
legacy of so many civilizations,
heritage that is so dear to
us, and also disseminating it.
So I'm very, very happy that
I have this opportunity,
and I couldn't have
obviously missed it.
Armenia is 25 years old.
I represented the generation
of independence.
I'm one of the people who went
on the streets to fight against,
to total [inaudible], to venture
into a totally unknown
territory of independence.
So Armenia has been
independent ever since.
But it was not alone.
Armenia had many friends, and
Armenia had incredible sons
and daughters scattered
all over the world.
Some of them ended up
in the United States.
Some of them, and most
of them maintain strong bonds
with their home country.
And I really was blessed to
benefit and enjoy that attachment,
that support, that also translated,
became a vector for our friendship
with our various countries,
including the United States.
The United States played
a tremendous role
in us becoming self-confident,
independent country,
despite formidable odds we have
been facing all these years.
And in all sectors of public
life, in economy and in culture.
The Library of Congress
is no exception.
For 20 consecutive years to host
Armenian lectures, events, exhibits,
we're so blessed, so thankful
to professionals, activists,
volunteers.
So from the bottom of my heart an on
behalf of the government of Armenia,
I thank you, Mr. Avdoyan,
your colleagues,
for your relentless activities that
we're, as I said, blessed with.
And as a token of our appreciation,
I want to, typically I go to places,
and I sit with a bottle of cognac,
which is the most known
Armenian product.
But that would be sacrilege
in the Library of Congress.
I got you one of he newest
albums we have out there on,
it's called The Immortals.
It recaps two millennial
for me in history.
It's a little naïve, but
it's a nice illustrated album
that I want you to
have here in congress.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: I have often
said to everyone who will listen
to when it comes to our
Armenian collections development
at the Library of Congress,
I'm a pig.
I want it all.
So, you can keep you cognac
today, but not tomorrow,
and I will delightfully accept this
book on the part of our division.
Now before proceeding
with the program,
I would like to speak briefly about
what today's 20th lecture means both
to me and to our division.
It is not only one of the longest
lasting series at the Library
of Congress, it is also a testament
to the success of the grant given
by Mrs. Marjory Dadian in 1991
for the quote/unquote health
and maintenance of the
Armenian collections.
And I'm really pleased to see in
the audience one of the people
who actually brokered that donation
with the late Dr. George Atiyeh,
our former section head of the near
east section, Dr. Christopher Murphy
who was in on the deliberations.
For particulars, I draw
your attention to the URL,
the internet address on the
second page of your program,
which will give you access to a blog
I wrote on this event with pictures.
Underneath that address is the URL
for the four corners
of the world blog.
I recently established foray
into social media by the curators
of the four area studies divisions
of the Library of Congress.
And I urge you to subscribe, because
you will have excellent narratives
from our curators in
those four divisions
on all of our rich collections.
Now Mrs. Dadian's gift
was given the same year
as Armenia's independence
was proclaimed.
I have since thought that both
the collections at the Library
of Congress and the republic
itself have grown together.
Certainly we have built
and maintained close ties
with the library and
librarians of the republic
and have an active partnership
with, at present, 14 of them.
Now in 1994 I created the Vardanant
selection to highlight all aspects
of Armenian life and culture by
presenting scholars, politicians,
musicians, artists and diplomats.
Many of the people who were keen
supporters then are no longer
with us.
Dr. George Atiyeh himself,
Mrs. Dadian who died too soon.
His Excellency Harry Gilmore,
first US ambassador to Armenia.
James McCloud, Varcas [inaudible],
and just recently Father
[inaudible],
whose face I can still see
in the audience, waiting,
just bursting to ask a question
after the speaker was finished.
Yet I see also many of the
original supporters in the audience,
including my sister who comes often.
I suspect to escape Houston.
And my colleagues at the library
such as Dr. Paul Crego,
who I know is here.
And my colleagues in AMED
whose support has literally
and figuratively made this event,
along with the support of, I saw,
Dr. Reuben Adalian of the
Armenian National Institute
and Aram [inaudible] of the Armenian
National Committee of America.
Yet the program rests
on the shoulders
of the presenters through the years.
Since 2000, these lectures
have been webcast,
and many are now available both
on our homepage and on YouTube.
And I'm pleased that David Mao
mentioned that the Peter Hrechdakian
and Hovann Simonian's
lecture on DNA and the orbs,
so the people have garnered more
than 62,000 views since
it was mounted.
And the number grows,
as do the numbers
of every lecture we presented.
All of this leads me to at
first thank you, our supporters.
To promise more programs in
the future of similar import.
And to introduce our speaker not by
her biography, which you will see
in the program, but rather
by describing how we
selected her to speak.
Earlier this year I was
contacted by the Journal
of Ecclesiastical History to see
if I would review an Armenian book.
This book turned out to be titled
Vigilant Powers, Three Churches
of Early Medieval Armenia
written by Dr. Christina Maranci.
I agreed. What I found was a book
with its roots firmly implanted
in traditional scholarship, detailed
research, delicate analysis,
and illustrative footnotes.
The much maligned footnote
is back, and I am delighted.
Yet this first book in English
about these churches was also set
within the context of the history
of the times and challenged many
of the historical assumptions
we have long maintained.
There was also a certain symmetry
in inviting Dr. Maranci to lecture
as she is, as Mary-Jane said, the
holder of the Arthur H. Dadian
at Tufts University, Arthur H.
Dadian, the husband of Marjorie
in whose name she had made her
generous grants to the library.
I consulted, as I always
do, with Mary-Jane.
Said I would like the
author to lecture.
She took one look at the
book and readily agreed.
So, at last, without
further explanation,
I would like to invite the Arthur
H. Dadian and Ara Oztemel professor
of Armenian art at Tufts
University, Dr. Christina Maranci,
to tell us about her A World
Monument, Zvart'nots', Armenia
and the Wars of the Seventh Century.
Dr. Maranci.
[ Applause ]
>> Christina Maranci:
Thank you so much Levon
for your kind introduction.
It is a great honor to give the
annual Vardanants Day talk I would
also like to thank the near
east section of the African
and Middle Eastern Studies
Division of the Library
of Congress for sponsoring my visit.
And it's a particular privilege
to offer my lecture in memory
of Marjorie Dadian whose good
offices, as Levon mentioned,
and those of her husband's, led
also to the creation of my own share
of Armenian art at Tufts University.
In honor of his 25th anniversary
of Armenia's independence,
I wish to focus today on one of the
most iconic of medieval monuments,
the Church of Zvart'nots'.
The form of Zvart'nots' has
inspired, both medieval and modern.
Zvart'nots' can be purchased in
miniature and watched in dance form.
Zvart'nots' appears on monetary
currency, and as all travelers
to Armenia know, Zvart'nots'
is the namesake
of the international
airport terminal.
It has also received more scholarly
attention than any other building
of the seventh century Caucuses.
So why so much attention
on Zvart'nots'?
One can offer several reasons.
First it was a patriarchal church.
It was built by the Catholicos
of Armenia, Nerses the Third
between circa 641 and 661.
Second, the Zvart'nots', even
in ruins, is a remarkable
and unique looking building.
For example, neither the nearby
seventh century churches of Hripsime
and Gayane, you see
them on the screen,
prepare one for the
unprecedented plan of Zvart'nots',
which combines a circle
and a tetraconch.
Third, there is the intriguing
problem of its original elevation.
Zvart'nots' collapsed in
the early 11th century,
and many scholars have proposed
hypothetical reconstructions
of which that of Toros Toramanian,
which you see on the screen,
has gained particular favor.
Quite aside from questions of its
plausibility, Toramanian's vision
of the church, with its three
successive and symmetrical tiers,
has achieved the status of an icon.
The beauty of his graphic image and
the brilliance of its solution forms
as much a part of the mystique of
Zvart'nots' as the ruins themselves.
And it's no wonder that a
portrait of Toramanian appears
at the west entrance of the church.
Zvart'nots' is one of
the three foci of my book
on seventh century architecture
entitled Vigilant Powers.
And in it, I wanted to step away
from the traditional methodologies
of Armenian architectural history.
Until very recently, work
in the field has focused
on the physical aspect of
buildings, their structure and form
on the documenting, describing and
categorizing of plans and elevations
and decorative motifs and mapping
developments from century to century
and monument to monument.
While this type of approach
is extremely valuable,
and I couldn't have done my more
interpretive work without it,
it easily gives the
impression of a sedate evolution
of building isolated from
the rest of the world.
But my study of Zvart'nots'
suggests the very opposite.
That Armenian architecture
of the seventh century,
when studied closely,
responded to and played a role
within the dramatic moment
in which it was created.
And that while scholars have
been frustrated in their attempts
to find a precise prototype
for Zvart'nots',
it finds satisfying
parallels in the realm
of history and geography writing.
And, in another iconic monument
produced only three decades
after Zvart'nots',
the Dome of the Rock.
First some background.
In the 640s Armenia was divided
between the Byzantine Empire
and the Sasanians,
but was de facto ruled
by local Armenian princely families.
By the 660s, the Sasanian at
Persian Empire had collapsed,
and power in the Eastern
Mediterranean
and the near east had shifted
from the Byzantines to Arabs.
The construction of Zvart'nots'
between 640 and 660 thus took place
at a critical transition in history,
which for many scholars
marks the dividing line
between late antiquity
and the Middle Ages.
A seventh century Armenian text,
the history attributed to Sebeos,
gives us precious insight
into this moment
from a local eyewitness perspective.
This text is valued by historians of
Armenia, Byzantium and early Islam
for its detailed and reliable
testimony and its consideration
of Armenian affairs within
a much broader context.
And it's particularly useful
for the information it gives
regarding the patron of Zvart'nots',
the patriarch Nerses, often called
the builder or [foreign word].
We learned from Sebeos
of Nerses' associations
with the Byzantine Empire and
Byzantine imperial interests.
In his earlier life we are told
Nerses studied their language,
Greek, and literature, and traveled
through their lands in
a military capacity.
The history also recounts how Nerses
accepted the Chalcedonian form
of Christianity adhered
to by the Byzantines.
Chalcedonianism called so for the
location of the church council
in 451 professed that Christ's two
separate and human, separate human
and divine natures subsisted
in Christ as a unity.
This creed was officially rejected
by Armenians in 506 who instead held
that the distinct humanity
and divinity of Christ resided
as one nature, Miaphysite,
in the incarnate logos.
This may seem like a rather subtle
point but was incredibly important
at the time and created
a major schism
between the Armenian
and Byzantine churches.
And Nerses' Chalcedonian
Christianity thus placed him
in opposition to the
traditional Armenian church,
gained him favor with
the Byzantines.
And the Byzantines,
through the 640s and 650s,
sought to consolidate
power in Armenia
through both military campaigns
and also doctrinal pressures
to get the Armenians to
convert to Chalcedonianism.
And in the 640s, the Byzantine
Emperor Constance even sought
to enforce this union
by forcing a communion,
a Chalcedonian Eucharistic
service in Armenia.
And on his second visit, when he did
this, apparently Nerses participated
in the Byzantine liturgy and tried
to force his fellow
clergy to do the same.
Some took part, others didn't.
And maybe because of the latter who
were outraged at Nerses' betrayal
of traditional Armenian
Christianity, Nerses went into exile
in Tyche, in northern, what
is now northeastern Turkey
but was part of historical Armenia.
And from there he went
to Constantinople.
So the history of Sebeos
gives us tremendous amount
of detailed information
about Nerses.
So between the emperor and the local
clergy, the local Armenian clergy,
Nerses was faced with two powerful
constituencies, and the foundation
of Zvart'nots' must be
interpreted in connection
with their competing interests.
Sebeos tells us that the church is
dedicated to the vigilant powers
from where my book gets its
name, in Armenian Zvart'nots'.
And these powers appeared in a
vision to the Armenian Saint Gregory
who was responsible for
converting Armenia to Christianity.
In his vision, Gregory saw
the vigilant powers as a host
of heavenly angels
[foreign language].
This is a very striking dedication
to the host of heavenly angels
and finds no precedent and invites
one to ask, why dedicate a church
to a host of angels instead of let's
say through Saint Gregory himself.
Here we note that the name
Zvart'nots' is a punning illusion
to Gregory's own name.
Because in Greek, Gregorigos
[phonetic] means vigilant
or watchful.
Since Nerses knew Greek,
it's entirely possible
that this linguistic play was
intended, and as for the host
of heavenly angels, the
Armenian word that we translate
as host is zork [phonetic] which,
like the Greek stratius [phonetic]
could hold meanings both angelic,
but also military.
And given the climate of the
seventh century eastern frontier
with is standing armies,
some of the most violent
of the Byzantine Empire, such a
desire for supernatural protection
of an angelic sort would
have been most appropriate.
The precise location of
Zvart'nots' is also significant.
According to Sebeos, Nerses located
his church near the holy city
of Vagharshapat, today the
holy Sea of Etchmiadzin.
On a route associated with the
meeting between Saint Gregory
and the pagan King Tridate.
Why, we might ask, did Nerses choose
this particular location on a road?
He could have built it up
farther or down lower on the road.
And maybe one reason is that unlike
the previous Armenian patriarch
of Devin [phonetic]
patriarch [inaudible] Devin,
which was in Paris [phonetic]
Armenia in the Persian sector
of Armenia, the location of
Zvart'nots' laid farther west,
closer to the Byzantine
controlled part of Armenia.
But another reason
concerns the landscape.
Zvart'nots' lies almost
directly north of Mount Ararat,
some 55 or 60 kilometers away.
And looking south to the
monuments, or really through it,
as you can now do, one sees
a perfectly centered image
of the mountain.
Of course, this is true for
many monuments in the proximity
of Ararat, which is the
tallest mountain in Asia minor.
But Zvart'nots' must have conveyed
a particularly strong effect
of graduated assent mounted on
an artificial circular terrace
about 38 meters in diameter.
Then on a stepped platform,
five meters tall.
An then on a second
stylobate of three steps.
The church rose in consecutive tiers
of diminishing diameter before
terminating in a drum and roof.
The relationship between Zvart'nots'
and Ararat, is evoked not only
by topography and physical
form, but also by the tradition
of Armenia's Christianization.
The same fifth century conversion
narrative containing the vision
of Gregory tells how the newly
Christian Armenian King Tirdate,
he was converted by Gregory, climbed
Mount Ararat or musces [phonetic]
as Armenians call it, to cut
the stones for the constructions
of the first churches of Armenia.
So the strong visual parallel
that must have obtained winds
of Zvart'nots' withstanding with
Mount Ararat in the background,
it's hard to imagine that
this was not intended.
So what did Nerses do?
He moved his patriarchal
residence close to the sacred city
of Vagharshapat and in close
relationship with Mount Ararat,
thus creating a link
with both the holy city
and with the holy mountain.
The plan of Zvart'nots'
is as remarkable
as its setting and dedication.
Its type is commonly referred
to in the architectural
literature as an Aisled tetraconch.
And this is a structure of two
shells, an inner and outer shell,
in which the inner one is formed
of four curving spaces,
like a four-leaf clover.
Forms of this type exist
across the Mediterranean world
and in the South Caucuses
too and Armenia and Georgia.
There are at least three
churches of this type.
But Zvart'nots' is the only church
for which a seventh century
date is firmly established.
According to the archeological
record, the largest group
of isle tetraconchs dates to about
450 to 550 and is found in Syria
and Mesopotamia at [Foreign Names]
to name the confirmed examples,
stood fifth and sixth
century double shell design
with a central quatrefoil
core in a protruding east end.
These monuments are similar to
Zvart'nots' also in their diameter,
so they're about the same in
terms of diameter, deviating only
about four meters from the
smallest example to the largest.
So this evidence has led a
lot of scholars to conclude
that Zvart'nots' belong to
a family of like monuments
in southern Asia Minor,
and these similarities
of these buildings seems
difficult to dispute.
Yet, the designers of
Zvart'nots' modified the plan
of these Syrian Mesopotamia
tetraconchs in significant ways.
First, the shape of its perimeter
wall does not reflect any
of the known precedence.
Zvart'nots' presents the first
preserved and dated example
of a circular exterior
enclosing a tetraconch.
Second, the designers of the
church also made a crucial addition
to the system of supports found
in the earlier tetraconchs.
And those blue circles
encircle the four single columns
that are adjacent to
the piers of the dome.
So the ones that's
sort of marked square.
These don't occur before.
So why are they there?
From a spatial perspective,
they occupy a critical
surface area in the ambulatory.
But in agreement with virtually
all the scholars to-date,
I want to draw your attention
to the way those little columns,
and let's see if I can point,
actually create an intermediate
circle so you have, you have a,
well [inaudible], right, circle.
And then the middle tier is
of this intermediate circle.
And then you have the
small circle in the middle
which is the [inaudible].
And this can be seen more
clearly on the cross-section.
I [inaudible] a cross section
where you have [inaudible] here.
So this seems very
different from those Syrian
and Mesopotamian tetraconchs.
And my belief is that this
adaptation of the Syrian
and Mesopotamian tetraconchs
was generated in order
to evoke the most famous
round monument of Christendom,
the Anastasis Rotunda in
Jerusalem to which we now turn.
Constructed in the fourth
century over the tomb of Christ,
the Anastasis Rotunda played a
central role in this ritual life
of Christians across the medieval
world and was no less important
to the Christian faithful
in early medieval Armenia.
While the archeology of this
building is even more complicated
than Zvart'nots', scholars
have proposed parallels
between the two buildings, not only
in their circular perimeter walls,
but also their tiered construction,
sculpted capitals and even
in their liturgical furniture.
These visual parallels are
supported by the historical moment
because seventh century Armenia
saw an increased interest
in the holy land as
attested in written sources.
We can consider, for example, a
description of the holy places
by the Armenian monk Hofsep
[phonetic], preserved in the history
of the Caucasian Albanians.
Hofsep's account of the rotunda,
which he visited, gives measurements
and many other details not found
in other medieval text, attesting,
for example, to the offset
rather than central position
of the tomb under the dome.
And on the left you see a plan,
a new archeological plan
of the Holy Sepulchre.
In the Anastasis Rotunda
you see that central form,
the two [inaudible] is not
centered within the circle.
Hofsep already attested to
that in the seventh century.
Hofsep also tells us about there's a
gallery level above the angulatory.
And also, he tells us the height
of the structure and the existence
of the relics within this building.
So this is a tremendously
important text that is neglected
by architecture historians
and archeologists.
In addition to this text, we
know from contemporary sources
that Armenians were aware of
and concerned about the welfare
of the sites and relics of the
holy land in the wake of the sack
of Jerusalem by the Persians in 614.
And for these reasons, the
Anastasis Rotunda would have been an
appropriate model to reproduce
in seventh century Armenia.
The elevation of Zvart'nots'
is as striking as its plan.
The arcades of the first tier were
composed of double colonnettes
with capitals in the
shapes of lilies.
And here you have a sort of a detail
of those capitals,
the lily capitals.
And above those capitals
were molded arcades.
Between those arches in the
spandrels were human figures.
And because of the wedge shape of
the pictorial field, the upper torso
of the human figures is shown in
full width, while the lower part
of the body is either concealed
behind he spandrel or squeezed
into its narrowing space.
And the example I just
showed you shows
that young men holding percussive
tools with short hair and a kind
of bloused garment and
then here are two more.
Again, they're holding building
tools which is very interesting.
Above this area was a sculpted field
filled with vegetal decoration.
There were bunches of fruit,
pomegranates and grape vines.
And then finally, at the op
of this first tier was a
kind of lattice work cornus.
So taken as a whole, this
is a striking composition,
much more extravagant in
its details and elements
than any other surviving early
medieval Armenian church.
And scholars also noticed
that the specific comgination
and organization of the lattice
work, the pomegranate motif
and the lily-shaped capitals
finds a parallel in descriptions
of the temples in Jerusalem, which
likewise describes lattice work,
von tagas [phonetic], lily
capitals and bronze pomegranates.
So the visitor to Zvart'nots' may
have interpreted those builders
on the facade.
Not just as those involved with
the construction of a church,
but also with the builders
of the temple in Jerusalem
and with the renovators of the
rotunda after the Persian sack.
And maybe most important
about those builders,
they glorify the act
of building itself.
Excavations in the early 20th
century uncovered a sundial,
which is now housed in
the archeologic museum,
and a modern reproduction
is kept outside.
The Zvart'nots' dial is important,
both for its particular qualities
and as a representative of a
robust but neglected corpus
of medieval sundials in Armenia.
And it should be said that
medieval dials are not common
in the Byzantine world,
although they are known
from places like the British Isles.
So by contrast, over 30 examples
from medieval Armenia alone
have been published thus far,
but this number is just a
fraction of the total surviving.
So whenever you go to Armenia, go
to the south façade of the church
and snap a picture if
you can find a sundial,
you may very well take a picture.
They're trying to collect
these dials.
The sundial of Zvart'nots' is the
earliest dated example from Armenia.
All the evidence suggests
that it formed part
of the original seventh century
complex, and it is also one
of the few ancient dials
accompanied by a motto.
The text reads in English, the
faithful shall pray to the Lord
in a fit time [foreign language].
Most appropriate for an
instrument that by its position
on the church must have served
to regulate liturgical time
and indicate the appropriate
time for services.
This object finds a companion in
another neglected dial discovered
by Robert Edwards in
1983 at the fortress
of Oltu [phonetic] in Tyche.
It features Armenian numerals
and a fragmentary Greek
inscription reading Nerses, bishop.
Given this name, the bilingual
Greek and Armenian inscriptions,
the tradition that places Nerses
in Tyche during his period of exile
and his well-known interests
in architectural patronage,
it is most likely that this
dial is his and belongs
to a now last seventh
century church in Oltu.
And if this is the case we can thank
sundials for mapping his movements.
The program of sculpture
continues on the inside.
The capitals of the Exedre
are large and finely carved
with thick bulging baskets and
spiral volutes framing a medallion.
These feature two different
cross monograms.
One reads narsu [phonetic]
of Nerses,
and the other reads
Catholico of the Catholicos.
Note here that as with the Oltu
sundial, Nerses uses Greek.
He also uses it on a foundation
inscription for Zvart'nots'
which simply reads
Nerses made, remember.
And it's possible to view
this use of Greek at a time
when Armenian had become the
standard writing language
as further evidence of Nerses'
relation with the Byzantine Empire.
The same can be said about the
use of Greek monogrammed capitals.
Monograms, otherwise unattested
in early medieval architecture
appear frequently
on sixth century Byzantine
monuments,
particularly in Constantinople.
They are situated with grand
and impressing buildings,
like the Church of
Saint Sergius and Bacchu
and at the Hagia Sophia,
as you see here.
And they appear in the corner
exedre of the buildings
in these curved spaces, just
like what we see at Zvart'nots'.
So in light of Nerses' background,
it's possible that he knew these
famous monuments of Constantinople
and sought to emulate
them in his own.
On each side of the exedre,
four magnificent eagles,
approximately one meter in height,
stood atop the single columns
in front of the dome pierce.
Two preserved eagles turn left.
The other two turn right,
inviting us to think
about them facing each other
across the curvature of the exedre.
Their impressive size and repetition
invites us to ask what they meant
to a contemporary viewer.
Bird watchers know best their
magnificence and fierceness.
And these connotations also pervaded
the ancient and late antique world
where eagles assumed multiple
and surely entangled connotations
of divinity, sovereignty and
victory in battle and the hunt.
In biblical Armenian and Syriac
[phonetic] textual traditions,
eagles were not only the symbol
of the evangelist John,
but also symbols of God.
In the vision of Saint Gregory,
God appears in the likeness
of a fleet-winged eagle,
reminding one of the extended wings
of the eagles at Zvart'nots' whose
upward curved feathers seemed poised
for flight.
In the Armenian tradition,
eagles also had military
connotations the simile
of the swooping eagle
[foreign language],
is found with great
frequency in the sources.
And in the official
art of Byzantium,
eagles embody worldly
authority and military power.
Byzantine lead seals, and
you see an example below,
provide a particularly compelling
comparison to Zvart'nots'
because their iconography includes
both cross monograms and eagles.
And it suggests that this seal
iconography might have been
deliberately appropriated,
particularly because
seals move easily,
and their impressions
are distributed widely.
Finally, eagles were
figures of the apocalypse.
The Armenia history of CBS records
a prophecy based on the book
of Daniel describing the four
great empires of the world.
The first, the Byzantines
are represented
by a lion with eagles wings.
These wings we are told, would be
plucked when the last great empire,
the Arabs, came to exterminate
all who came before it.
The massive outstretched
wings of the eagles
of Zvart'nots' may thus have evoked
not only the magnificence of empire,
but also called to mind the
final days of the world.
Before leaving our survey of
Zvart'nots' we need to make note
of what for me is its most curious
element, the Urartian Stele.
Discovered in 1900 during the
excavation, it bears a text
of 47 lines in Urartian Cuneiform
identifying the seventh century B.C.
King Rusa the Second and his
building and irrigation works.
The original location of
this stele is uncertain,
but accounts of the
discovery make clear
that it was discovered not below
the level of the church but rather
within its medieval context.
The reports do not mention any
evidence for Urartian constructions
at Zvart'nots' which might otherwise
explain the presence of the stele.
And it bears noting that the
stone's [inaudible] or base
into which the stele was
inserted was never found,
despite repeated searches.
All of this invites us to
think about the possibility
that the stele was transported to
the site from its original location,
whether near or far,
and deliberately reused
during the building campaign
of Nerses the Third.
And indeed the first
archeologists of Zvart'nots' assumed
that it formed part
of the church portal.
Such reuse of building
materials is not unusual.
It was widely practiced
in the late antique
and early medieval
churches in Byzantium.
But while those churches
used classical spolia,
and those churches, the use
of classical spolia has
been carefully studied,
much less attention has
been given to the reuse
of building materials
in an Armenian context.
In Armenia, recycled materials
derive for a much more remote past.
And they are separated by a
millennium from their new contexts.
So we want to ask again,
why did this reuse occur?
It seems very unlikely that it had
to do with building materials given
that we're talking about an area
where stone was and is abundant.
So I offer an extended
explanation in my book
because the early medieval Armenian
texts offer a remarkable discussion
of Cuneiform inscriptions
attributing them to the Assyrians,
like the Queen Shamiram
or to imperially appointed
Armenian governors and prefects.
And taking such a medieval
understanding of the Urartian past
into account, we can imagine that
Cuneiform with its visual message
of antiquity and authority, would
have served a useful purpose
for Nerses who's church and
residence could not boast
like the holy Sea of Etchmiadzin, a
fourth century foundation tradition.
And whose own status as
patriarch was contested
by the local elites and clergy.
And here's just another example of
a very interesting Urartian stele
that was re-carved with a
cross in the Middle Ages.
So far you should have a sense
of the tremendous richness
of Zvart'nots' and its connections
to a great range of traditions
and individual monuments.
In its dedication and location,
its ground plan, inscriptions,
sculpture, Zvart'nots' can be
linked to Byzantium to the Holy Land
to Syria, Mesopotamia and to local
Armenian forms and conventions.
The complexity of this
monument and the diversity
of its features has
frustrated attempts to assign it
to a single art historical category.
And arguments regarding the
origins of Zvart'nots' are divergent
and sometimes contradictory.
Scholars view it as a copy
of the Anastasis Rotunda,
as one of a family of
buildings in Syria.
As an evocation of
monuments in Constantinople.
Or as a purely Armenian phenomenon.
All of these arguments tend to
focus on one or another aspect
of the monument rather than
treating it as a whole.
And another way it's
discussed is as a mixture.
And Toramanian calls it a mixture or
[foreign word] of Roman Byzantine,
Greek and Armenian styles.
So in closing I'd like to offer my
own view of the monument and suggest
that in focusing strictly on the
formal and physical parallels
for Zvart'nots', we have
ignored an alternative
and perhaps even more
compelling body of evidence
in contemporary written text.
Armenian historical and
geographical writing
of the seventh century shows
an unprecedented interest
in situating Armenia within a
larger supra national sphere.
The [foreign word] or
geography attributed
to [foreign name] offers an
extended geographical description
of the known world and
Armenia's position within it.
It's the first line to
the text to have survived
from early medieval
Armenia, and it is also one
of the earliest preserved examples
of Armenian secular literature.
The Anonymous Chronicle,
another text from the seventh
century inserts Armenian historical
notices into a broader
ecclesiastical history.
The first part of the text outlines
world history and includes lists
of Roman emperors and Susanian
kings and also includes a set
of Armenian notices and traditions.
So again, Armenian traditions,
like with the [foreign language]
are inserted into a broader frame.
The history of [inaudible],
so important to the study
of Zvart'nots' also offers
an instructive parallel
to Zvart'nots' fusion of traditions.
This text offers a detailed
narrative of the period leading
up to the early Arab
conquests, as I mentioned,
and the conflicts among
the Byzantine Persian
and Islamic powers.
The history places Armenia again
within a broader historical
tradition,
considering extra national
events that were not
of immediate local concern.
Scholars have observed over 25 years
ago that the universalizing nature
of these texts may
have been motivated
by the cataclysmic events
of the seventh century.
The Persian capture
of Jerusalem in 614,
the faltering of the
Byzantine Empire,
the demise of the Susanian
Dynasty, and ultimately the arrival
of the Arabs, all, and I quote
here scholar, require the expansion
in both time and space of
the traditional framework
of Armenian national historiography.
It was no longer possible to be
limited to purely local history.
National Armenian historiography
necessarily opened itself
to the universal.
This is talking about
the seventh century.
And as an art historian,
I think this trend obtains
beyond the realm of text.
In situating Armenia
within a universal frame,
whether in geographic, chronographic
or historical cosmic terms,
seventh century writing finds a
powerful parallel in the church
of Zvart'nots', the evidence we
have considered does not suggest a
monument out of place
in a local context.
On the contrary, it reveals one
in which local traditions
were integrated
within a broadly recognizable
set of forms and practices.
Like contemporary texts, Zvart'nots'
locates Armenian tradition
within a much broader
geographical sweep.
The written evidence thus allows us
to acknowledge rather than ignore
or explain away the fusion
of traditions of Zvart'nots'
and to interpret this fusion
as a deliberate attempt
to mount a local shrine
on the world stage.
In this sense, the study
of Zvart'nots' demonstrates
the limitations
of an exclusively visual analysis.
At the same time, it shows the
degree to which material culture
and architectural culture formed
part of the larger thought world
of the seventh century frontier.
All of this brings me to the
Dome of the Rock known to Muslims
as [foreign language]
or the noble sanctuary.
Located in Jerusalem
on the Temple Mount,
the Dome of the Rock was
completed in 691 to 2
under the Umayyad Caliph
Abd al-Malik.
Like Zvart'nots', it
draws its conspicuous plan
from Byzantine building practices,
most likely in Syria
and the Holy Land.
Both Zvart'nots' and the Dome
of the Rock are centralized,
aisled and domed.
Both of them are distinguished
by their elevated position.
The situation of the
Dome of the Rock
on the temple mount recalls the
unusually tall polygonal platform
of Zvart'nots'.
And both the Christian and
the Islamic building rise
in a series of successive tiers.
The exterior of the
Dome of the Rock,
particularly before the
Safavid era renovation
with colored tiles would have
recalled Zvart'nots' the lowest
level or data when you
see drawings on the right
of a French archeologist,
Clermont Ganneau.
The lowest level or data supported
a course of shallow based divided
by pilasters and arcades.
And above this was the parapet
with its original decoration
of small arches divided
by double colonnettes.
This parapet evokes the Zvart'nots'
because surviving fragments
at the church indicate
that the inexistence
of upper level of arcading.
The interior mosaics and
tie beams of the Dome
of the Rock present
rich vegetal forms
that include open lily-like flowers,
grapevines and pomegranates.
And both churches remarkably,
and I'm not the one to say this,
Lorenz Neace said it at
the University of Delaware.
Both churches use eagle capitals.
At the Dome of the Rock, these
capitals are partially faced,
but they are in many
cases still discernable
and form an interesting
point of correspondence
with the eagle capitals on the
four domed piers of Zvart'nots'.
Now, in outlining these
correspondences, I am not claiming
that Zvart'nots' is a prototype
for the Dome of the Rock.
So, let's just get that out there.
I'm much less interested in
exploring the possible seriality
of the relationship than
in placing these monuments
in dialogue with each other.
The physical evidence suggests ways
in which their resemblance may
be linked to common sources
of inspiration, most of
all the Anastasis Rotunda
and the temple mount.
If Zvart'nots' may be understood
to evoke these two holy sites
in many different ways, the
features it shares with the Dome
of the Rock may also be
linked to common sources
and similar strategies of emulation.
It's also intriguing to reflect
on the possible reasons
behind these strategies.
The patrons of both
buildings rose to power
in atmospheres of contestation.
And both the Dome of the Rock
and Zvart'nots' may be seen
as articulations of
legitimate and sacred authority.
The assertion of this
authority in both the caliphal
and patriarchal commissions
resulted in powerful geometric forms
in the consolidation
of older traditions,
both imperial and sacred.
And most of all in dramatic
marks on the landscape.
Each building constitutes an
architectural focal statement,
a visual magnet drawing
attention to itself.
And if I'm correct in viewings
of Zvart'nots' as an attempt
to mount the world stage of
the latter seventh century,
both monuments can be
understood in relation
to the dynamic changes brought
about by contemporary conflicts,
and more specifically, the
ascendance of Arab control.
So just to conclude.
Produced by separate religious,
ethnic and political communities,
Zvart'nots' and the Dome of the Rock
are most often discussed separately.
Yet they stand as remarkable
and complementary expressions
of their age and of the
potential for monuments to respond
and to give shape to a
dynamic moment in history.
And for these reasons, Zvart'nots'
serves not only as a symbol
of the modern nation of Armenia,
but also as a world monument.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: I think
you now see why I thought
that Dr. Maranci would
be the perfect.
Thank you Mr. Ambassador.
He's called away for meetings.
We certainly appreciate
his presence.
At all events I want to tell you
that Dr. Maranci's book is not only
about Zvart'nots', it's also about
two other seventh century churches,
Maran [phonetic], which is in sad
shape, and Dr. Maranci has called
for universal help in
guaranteeing its survival
and the Church of [inaudible].
It was published by [inaudible].
I am not supposed to be a commercial
up here, but if you're interested
in her lecture you would be
interested in her superb book.
Thank you, Christina.
It was truly wonderful
food for thought.
And speaking of food for thought, I
now invite you to a marvelous lunch
that the Lebanese Taverna
has provided for us.
And I look forward to seeing
each and every one of you
at the next Vardanants Day lecture.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.